welcome back to pj chain design today we
are going to talk about how to build a
structure specific the one in the center
to make it more sun ray style are you
ready let's get started
so i'm going to starting a straight line
starting from the center
and going for whatever how tall you want
it to be
this is not really i'm going to print it
out just want to show you
the wave of making it so the size is
actually doesn't matter to me
and i'm going to rotate and make sure
copy equal
yes i'm going to have 12 of them at the
end for 360 degree
so i'm going to divide it 360
into 24 and make a curve on the left and
make a curve from the right 360 divided
by 24
if you don't have the calculator you can
do something like that
okay and we want to do the same thing
divided by 24 and that will be something
like that so we need to create the space
uh the shape in between those space so
what i'm going to do next is
draw a line here and snapping into the
midpoint coming into the top
and do the same here snapping into the
midpoint coming to the top
so then we got this shape here we don't
need to have those two reference lines
so we can delete
it now if we pick up those two curves
over here
and you notice that you have control
point is on
so we're gonna pick up the cur the point
not the curve
and just moving this two up so you got
something like this
so to creating the surface i would like
to have
loft and only loft from here to here and
then you get that
surface i'm going to loft again from
this curve
to this curve so then i got this one
and we can go ahead to join them
together because
we did the right calculation if you pick
up this one and you do
polar array and snapping into the zero
and we want to have 12 of them
you will have something like this okay
so that will be
the first part now let's take a look on
this view right here the second part i
want to create in
this area over here so the easiest way
is i'm going to use the all snap make
sure you're snapping into the endpoint
and snapping into the endpoint so let me
turn this
into the red color that easier for you
to see
now with this one i'm going to use the
mirror command and
pick up this curve and mirror from this
point to
this point so next things we want to
make a straight line snapping to the end
point to the end point
and to creating the surface we are going
to use the loft
we're gonna loft from here to here and
also from here
to here all right don't forget to
join them and also let me turn them into
other color
it's easier for you to see so now i have
that even though this is not exactly on
our construction plane that's okay
because we know there are 12 of them
so let's go ahead to polar array again
and we can do 12 of them so you become
like this with
a lot of facet if you take a render view
then you got something like that
and you can continue to build this one
going up even more and getting bigger
and bigger to create your own pattern
i'm going to stop it here and show you
how to get
them into the solid let me join all of
them together
they should able to join because all the
surface edges is actually touching
perfectly
all right so i'm going to use the
commands duplicate border
and i'm going to duplicate border of
that one as you can see
it's follow the h over there and i'm
going to go
on the top view use a command project
to cplane and make sure that you want to
delete the input
so now you can see they are completely
flat
with that one we are going to make it
into the surface by extruded stray
and then now we have this surface there
we are going to use that to trim off the
surface on the top
so if we join rest of it together
then we will have this high over there
now if you feel like this is too fat uh
what you can do is you can draw another
line
go over on the bottom and simply just
trim it
on the bottom over here so now if you
look at the bottom
it looks like a couple of box so
to make it into the solid we're using
the cap command
then this one will be completely solid
let's take a look on the render view
so now you have a high all right so now
this is the basic shape we can coming
over there
for the stone setting so i'm bringing
one of the stone you want to know
how to make this stone i have on the
right top corner to show you
how to make the diamond video or you can
download this stone
for your practice the link is in the
description below
okay so for this though i'm going to
turn everything else
off so it's easier for you to see first
of all we need to make
a undersea bezel and i'm going to
snapping into the vertex over here
and bring it down just about like this
one
and for about this long as long as your
cooler does not stick it out you will be
fine
and then uh we do need to have a bevel
edges
so that's using the chamfer command
and we want to chamfer this one for
maybe
0.3 millimeter and let's pick up the h
inside and then so that is chamfers you
can see there's a chamfer there so it's
a more friendly for your jeweler
let's turn on this one and see this is
kind of a little bit too low so i'm
going to bring up just a little bit
we don't actually need that long but we
can trim it later with the prong
together
so i'm going to do is draw a straight
line snapping into the zero
and bring down something like this and i
also want to bring it
over close to my stone so let's turn
off everything so we can just deal in
with this one and also turn the stone
into other color and we simply just need
to
pipe with this pipe this one so let's go
ahead
to use the pipe command and for
something
about this size make sure the pipe is
rounded on the top and we want to move
in just a little bit
make sure you are not cutting too much
of the prong the prong will break
to make it look nice to fitting in this
space i do like to have
three prongs that are four prong so what
i like to do
is pick up this prong and i'm going to
use the
rotate command and copy equal yes
i'm going to starting with here for the
first one
is 120 degree the second one is 260
degree
so then we'll i'll get it perfectly like
this now if you
turn on what you have there and you like
the result
then you can boolean them but for the
casting purpose
this one is not touching so that way
you won't have a good casting what i
like to do
is actually moving this down so they are
actually touching
and sometimes i'll intentionally make
this slightly bigger
just because i will have a better
casting over there
all right so now this is what we have
i'm going to
boiling all of this by bowling union
and i also want to draw a box to cut out
the rest of it
and to be even on the bottom
so i'm going to use a bowling difference
this one
out of the box so the bottom will be
flat
again we are going to use the polar
array we know there's a number 12
over there so let's hit the center and
then
number is 12 then we'll have all of them
there
once you add the jump ring you put the
bell then it can be a pendant or it can
be
an earring write it down in the comments
let me know what you think
about this technique and thank you for
watching i'll see you next
[Music]
you